สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาตี้สวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีครับนักเรียนเยๆกลับมา
เจอกับครูอตี้กับครูพี่เอ๋ในช่อง
comprehensible ไยนะครับข้างบนนะคะอ่า
ใช่อยู่ข้างบนข้างบนอค่ะก่อนที่เราจะคุย
กันวันนี้วันอะไรคะอ่าวันนี้ใช่มั้ยครับ
วันนี้วันนี้
วันวันนี้วันโอ้เดี๋ยวนะวันนี้วันจันทร์
วันจันทร์ตัวเล็กตัวเล็กนิดนึงนักเรียน
เห็นมยมองเห็นมยนักเรียนนักเรียนก็นัก
เรียนบอกว่าเข้าใจแล้วครูอาร์ตี้กับครู
เอ๋อ่ะวันจันทร์ทุกคลิปอใช่วันจันทร์ทุก
คลิปค่ะวันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่รู้มั้ยวัน
นี้วันที่ 5 ค่ะอวันที่ 5 ใช่ครับ
อ่าเดือนอะไรคะอ่าเดือนนี้เดือนกัยายนอ
เดือนกันยายนอ่าใช่ครับเดือนใหม่และเดือน
กันยายนและ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะอ่าปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับอ่า
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะอ่าค.ศ
2022 ใช่ครับค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะอ่า
ตอนนี้เวลา 20:00
น
2035 น
2035 นะคะอ่าใช่ครับนักเรียนตื่นตื่น
แล้วใช่มคะอ่าตื่นแล้วนะตื่นแล้วแล้วก็
กินข้าวนักเรียนอาจจะกินข้าวอยู่แล้วก็ดู
เราไปด้วยอ่าใช่นะคะอ่าซีรีส์นี้ครูอาตี้
กับครูเอ๋ก็ต้องคุยธุระกันตลอดอ่าใช่ครับ
มีเรื่องมีธุระที่จะมาคุยกันนะครับวันนี้
เราจะคุยเอ่อธุระอะไรกันดีครับมีธุระอะไร
มั้ยอ่าวันนี้หลอคะวันนี้จริงๆก็ไม่เชิง
ธุระเอ๊ะหรือธุระอ่าเป็นอะไรคืออย่างงี้
ครูอาตี้ครูอาตี้เนี่ยเอ่อ
เป็นเป็นเป็นผู้ชายเนาะคือเราก็จะคิดว่า
ผู้ชายจะมีอะไรบางเรื่องที่เก่งกว่าผู้
หญิงอ๋อใช่ครับบางเรื่องครับผู้หญิงก็จะ
มีอะไรบางเรื่องที่เก่งกว่าผู้ชายเป็น
ความคิดเมื่อก่อนนะอย่างเช่นผู้หญิงเนี่ย
จะทำอาหารเก่งกว่าอือฮึจริงมยอ่ะอ่าก็
จริงมั้ยส่วนใหญ่ส่วนใหญ่น่าจะ
จริงแต่เชฟส่วนใหญ่ก็เป็นผู้ชาย
อ่ะอย่างเงี้ยเป็นต้นนักเรียนคนไทยจะคิด
ว่าคนไทยจะคิดว่าทำอาหารเป็นหน้าที่ผู้
หญิงอืใช่มั้ยคะอย่างที่บ้านครูอาตี้ครู
อาตี้หรือภรรยาทำอาหารค่ะอ่าครูอตี้เป็น
คนทำอาหารเอง
โอยโอเคค่ะแสดงว่าไม่จริงใช่มั้ใช่เอพะ
ที่บ้านครูเออ๋นะคุณแม่ก็ทำอาหารไม่อร่อย
อรอครับคุณพ่อทำอาหารอร่อยแต่พ่อก็ไม่
ค่อยทำแต่ทีนี้วันนี้นะก็จะอันนี้เป็น
เรื่องที่ผู้หญิงทเบอกเบอกว่าเป็นเรื่อง
ที่ผู้หญิงต้องทำคือทำอาหารนะคะอคนไทยบอก
นะคะคนไทยเมื่อก่อนแต่มีเรื่องที่เป็นที่
ผู้ชายต้องทำอย่างเช่นถ้าเกิดจะไปเที่ยว
หรือไปไหนเนี่ยผู้ชายต้องขับรถรถใช่มั้ย
คะอ่าใช่ผู้ชายก็จะเป็นคนขับอ่ะที่บ้าน
ครูอาตี้เวลาไปเที่ยวครูอาตี้ขับรถหรือ
ภรรยาขับรถค่ะอ่าครูอาตี้จะเป็นคนขับออ
ครูอาตี้เป็นคนขับนะดีเลยค่ะเพราะว่าเอขอ
โทษนะคะขอโทษถามเรื่องส่วนตัวขอโทษค่ะไม่
เป็นไรครับหัวตี้ขับรถตลอดเวลาไปไหนก็ขับ
คนเดียวอืจะถามว่าภรรยาขับรถเป็นมยคะอ๋อ
ขับได้ภรรยาก็ขับรถได้ครับเป็นอ๋ออ๋อเก่ง
เก่งมากค่ะคือปัจจุบันก็มีผู้หญิงที่ขับ
รถเก่งใช่เค่ะแต่รุ่นรุ่นเอ๋ก็มีบางบางคน
นะไม่ใช่บางคนเยอะเลยค่ะขับรถไม่ได้รุ่น
เอ๋นะคะรุ่นเอ๋นะแต่แต่แต่ว่าผู้หญิงสมัย
ใหม่เขับรถได้นะคะบางคนไปเรียนเรียนซ่อม
รถด้วยนะอืู้เอ๋มีเพื่อนเป็นรุ่นน้อง
เรียนขับรถแล้วก็ไปเรียนซ่อมรถคือถ้าเา้า
บอกว่าถ้าขับรถไปคนเดียวรถมี
ปัญหาเค้าก็จะต้องรู้ว่าทำไมรถมีปัญหาใช่
อฮะได้ซ่อมได้ใช่ค่ะวันแนี้ครูเอ๋ก็เลยจะ
ถามครูอาตี้เพราะว่าครูเอ๋เนี่ยขับรถไม่
เป็นอ๋ออ่าได้ครับแล้วครูเอ๋ก็เคยมี
เพื่อนที่ขับ
รถขับรถได้ขับรถได้ขับรถ
เป็นเหมือนกันเหมือนกันใช่มั้เหมือนกัน
เออขับรถได้ขับได้ขับได้ขับเป็นขับเป็น
มั้ยอ่าคือคือขับรถได้ขับเท่านั้นอือฮึ
เออขับเท่านั้นแต่ว่าไม่รู้เรื่องข้างใน
รถนะคะออครับมาอ่ะเดี๋ยวคุเอ๋ไม่มีรูปให้
ดูอ่าอ๋อมีรูปด้วยใช่มั้ยครับโอเคใช่เป็น
รูปโอเคอ่ะมีอยู่ครั้งนึงอุ๊ยมามั้ยครุ
อาตี้
อ่ามาแล้วครับขึ้นหน้าจอแล้วครับมานะคะอ
ใช่คือมีอย่างงี้ค่ะครูอาตี้มีอยู่ครั้ง
นึงอ่าเอ๋เนี่ยเอ๋กับเอ๋อยู่ที่
บ้านนะ
คะอุ๊ยจริงๆมี 2 ครั้งเอ๋นะอยู่ที่บ้านนะ
คะอยู่ที่บ้านแล้วก็อยู่ที่บ้านกับเพื่อน
อีกคนนึงก็มีก็มีมีมีเพื่อนรุ่นพี่ที่ทำ
งานอ่าตอนนั้นไม่ได้เป็นครูนะคะก็ขับรถมา
ใช่มขับรถมาข้างหน้าบ้านอ๋อมาบ้านครูเออ๋
ใช่มั้ยออ่ะใช่ค่ะมาข้างหน้าบ้านขับรถ
มานะอ่ามีนัดกันเพื่อนจะมาแต่ว่าเอ๊ะทำไม
ยังไม่มาทำไมยังไม่มาแล้วเพื่อนก็
โทรศัพท์มาบอกครับรอก่อน
นะรออ่าบอกให้รอก่อน
โอเคเอ่อมีปัญหาอะไร
เอ่อรถมันไม่รู้เป็นอะไรมันกึกๆกึกๆอ๋อ
มันอ่าวิ่งมาไม่ได้ใช่มั้ยมันจะหยุดโอเค
ใช่คือรถเนี่ยมันไม่มันไม่ได้ไปไม่ได้ไป
ไม่ใช่วิ่งไปได้ปกติอ่ะครับแล่นบางทีเรา
พูดวิ่งบางทีพูดแล่นเนาะอือไม่ได้แล่นไป
ปกติก็ปรากฏว่าพอมาถึงหน้าบ้านรถมาจอด
หน้าบ้านนะคะอ่ายังคืออ่ะลเราพูดวาดรถตรง
นี้ละกันรถเป็นอย่างงี้เลยนะ
คะอันนี้กระโปรงหน้า
อ่ะอันนี้คนขับอยู่ตรงนี้นะคะอันนี้
กระโปรงหลังพอรถจอดปั๊บเนี่ยยังไม่ได้
เปิดกระโปรงนะ
ครับมีควัน
อ๋อมีควันขึ้นมามีควันขึ้นมาจากกระโปรง
หน้ารถใช่มั้ยครับใชใช่แล้วเพื่อนก็เปิด
ว่าอ้ายช่วย
ด้วยทำยังไงทีนี้ทำยังไงตกใจเลยใช่มั้ย
เอ๊ะทำไมรถมีควันขึ้นใช่แล้วอยู่ข้างใน
เนี่ย 2 คนครับครูเอ๋ก็ผู้หญิงขับรถไม่
เป็นแล้วครนี้เพื่อนอีกคนนึงขับรถไม่เป็น
เพื่อนคนนี้เรียนขับรถไม่นานอ่าอเพิ่งขับ
เป็นใช่น่าจะขับได้ประมาณ 6 เดือนมั้งอ๋อ
โอเค 6 เดือนนะคะประมาณเนี้ยแล้วก็มีควัน
ขึ้นทำยังไงดีคะครูอาตี้อ่าก็ต้องลงมาจาก
รถก่อนครับอเปิดประตูแล้วก็ลงดับเครื่อง
ก่อนต้องดับเครื่องก่อนข้อ 1 ต้องดับ
เครื่องก่อนปิดสวิตช์ก่อนนะครับอืค่ะปิด
สวิตช์รถดับเครื่องลงมาดับเครื่องใช่เปิด
เปิดกระโปรงหน้าเลยได้มั้ยคะอ่าอ่าเปิด
กระโปรงหน้าเลยได้มยต้องดูว่าควันควัน
เยอะมั้ยถ้าควันเยอะต้องรอก่อนรอแป๊บใช่ๆ
ถ้าเราทำไม่เป็นน่ะเราช็อกไปแล้วอ่ะ
อ๋อถ้าถ้าทำไม่เป็นก็ปล่อยมันแล้วก็เดิน
ออกมาเดินเข้าไปรออยู่ในบ้านครับดีที่สุด
มันไม่ระเบิดตู้มใช่มั้ยอ่ามันไม่ระเบิด
ถ้าเราดับดับเครื่องแล้วก็ไม่ระเบิดครับ
แล้วก็รอรอให้ควันมันหายไปค่อยไปเปิดดู
เราเราต้องโทรศัพท์ตามช่างมั้ยคะอ่าโอเค
ก็ถ้ารีบไปแล้วก็อยากจะให้ช่างมาดูก็
โทรศัพท์ตามช่างได้ค่ะนะครับอืแต่ว่าถ้า
ไม่ไม่รีบก็รอใช่รอรอแล้วค่อยเปิดดูว่าออ
เป็นอะไรอ่าแล้วค่อยอ่าถ้ารู้มีความรู้ก็
ค่อยๆดูว่าเป็นอะไรแล้วแก้ไขอใช่ถ้าเรา
ไม่รู้อ่ะอ่าถ้าไม่รู้ก็ตามช่างแน่นอน
ครับถ้าไม่รู้ก็ตามช่างแน่
นอนเคสนี้เพื่อนตกใจมากอ๋อแล้วเพทำยังไง
ครับเพก็เฮ้ยช่างที่ไหนช่างอ้ารู้จักช่าง
มั้ยใช่หาช่างแต่โชคดีโชคดีว่ามีบ้านตรง
นี้อ๋อมีเพื่อนบ้านใช่มั้ยอ่ามีเพื่อน
บ้านแล้วที่นี่มีผู้ชาย
อืผู้ชายคนนี้เค้าก็ขับรถเป็นใช่มั้ยคะ
รู้จักกันอือ่าเค้าก็ถาม
ว่าเป็นอะไรรถเป็นอะไรเพราะว่าเขาก็เห็น
เห็นควันขึ้นมาที่เ่อจากรถใช่มั้ยครับอ่า
ก็เลยถามก็ถามเป็นอะไรออ่อเพื่อนก็บอกว่า
ไม่
รู้ไม่รู้รถเป็นอะไรตอนเนี้ยรถมีควันขึ้น
แล้วก็ไปไม่ได้อ่าไปไม่ได้โอเคใช่มรถมัน
กึกๆๆๆกๆก็ปรากฏว่าก็เค้าก็มาแล้วรอรถ
เย็นเบอกเเหมือนเหมือนอาตี้บอกก็คือครับ
รอรถเย็นก่อนใช่รอให้ควันหมดก่อนแล้วค่อย
เปิดดูนะเปิดมาก็ยังมีอยู่นิดหน่อยนะจริง
ๆแล้วเกิดจากอะไรคะครูอาตี้อ๋ออันนี้ก็
เกิดจากเ่อครูอาตี้คิดว่าเกิดจากน้ำน้ำ
ที่อยู่ในหม้อน้ำที่ใช้ระบายความร้อน
เนี่ยน้ำหมดอ่ะเดี๋ยวนะูเอู๋เอ๋มีมีรูป
หน้ารถให้ดูอ่า
โอเคน้ำตัวไหนอ่ะอ่าน้ำที่อยู่ในข้างหน้า
รถตรงนี้ครับที่มีฝาปิดสีเหลืองเหลืองอัน
นี้เหรอคะเหลืองใช่ๆๆอันนี้นะใช่ครับอ่า
อันนี้น้ำในเนี้ยครับหมดอ๋อถ้าอย่างงั้น
ถ้าเราเปิดขึ้นมาเราเปิดฝาเลยได้มั้ยอ่า
เปิดฝาได้ครับแต่ตอนนี้ตอนที่ควันขึ้นตรง
นี้ก็ก็จะร้อนมากค่ะใช่จะร้อนมากแล้วมี
ควันขึ้นมาจากตรงนี้อ๋อแล้วถ้าเราเปิดเลย
อ่าเปิดเลยเอ่อันมันก็จะขึ้นมาน้ำที่ร้อน
ๆที่อยู่ข้างในที่มีน้ำอยู่นิดหน่อยมันก็
จะร้อนมากแล้วมันก็จะขึ้นมาอาจจะทำให้น้ำ
เนี่ยเอ่อูมือเราใช่เราก็จะร้อนืออเรา
ต้องรอให้มันเย็นก่อนรอให้ควันมันหมดก่อน
อ๋อใช่ครับหมายความว่าน้ำตรงเมันแห้งเลย
เหรอคะครูอใช่ครับน้ำมันจะแห้งไปพอมัน
เหลือน้อยมันก็จะยิ่งร้อนมากอ๋อก็แปลว่า
เครื่องจะร้อนใช่ใช่อเอ๊ะแล้วปกติน้ำ
อันเนี้ยจะใช้กี่วันหมดคะอ๋อน้ำอันนี้
ปกติจะไม่หมดครับแต่เราก็จะต้องดูดูบ่อยๆ
ประมาณ 1 เดือนเราก็ดูอออ่าจะมีที่ที่
เติมน้ำอยู่มีที่เติม
น้ำ
เดี๋ยวนะน้ำตรงนี้ใช่เวลาเราเติมน้ำคือ
น้ำธรรมดาเหรอคะน้ำใช้น้ำธรรมดาได้ครับ
อ๋อแลแล้วไอ้ตัวนี้ล่ะคืออะไรอ่ะอ่าตรง
นี้เป็นถังพักน้ำ
อ๋อใช่ครับค่ะเป็นเป็นน้ำเดียวกันกับใช่
น้ำเดียวกันกับที่อยู่ในหม้อน้ำใช่ครับ
ใช่ครับแล้วเวลาเติม 1 ครั้งเนี่ยมันต้อง
เยอะแค่ไหนอ่ามันจะมีอ่าครูเออ๋กลับไปที่
รูปเมื่อกี้ก่อนครับค่ะ
อ่านี่เวลาเราเติมมันจะมีด้านล่างที่
เขียนว่ามินที่สามเหลี่ยมชี้ลงมาเส้นข้าง
ล่างตรงนี้ใช่มั้ยคะเส้นข้างล่างอ่าออค่ะ
มันจะมี 2 เส้นถ้าเติมจนอยู่เส้นข้างล่าง
แปลว่าน้อยเกินไปอ๋อตรงนี้นะคะอ่าตรงนี้
แปลว่าน้อยเกินไปเราต้องเติมให้ไปอยู่
เส้นข้างบนครับออเส้นนี้นะคะใช่อยู่เส้น
ข้างบนนี้โอเคอ๋อแล้วมากกว่านี้ได้มั้ยคะ
อ่ามากมากกว่านี้เอ่อไม่ดีครับอ๋อมันจะ
ล้นรอคะใช่มันจะล้นมันจะล้นถามทำไมนะครู
เอกเติมที่ตามเส้นที่เขาบอกเอาไว้ครับ
อย่าให้มากเกินอย่าให้น้อยเกินให้อยู่ตรง
กลางตรงกลางเอ๊ะเดี๋ยวครูอาตี้เติมเนี่ย
หมายความว่าเราเติมจากจากอันนี้ใช่มั้ยคะ
จากสีเหลืองใชใชสีเหลเติมตรงนี้ได้ค่ะ
เติมตรงโน้นก็ได้เหมือนกันออตรงนี้ก็มี
ที่เติมเหมือนกันเพราะว่าเป็นที่เวกันน้ำ
ก็จะไหลไปเจอกันอ๋อใช่ใช่ครับ
เอ่อแล้วครูอาตี้บอกน้ำตัวเนี้ยเป็นน้ำ
ระบายความร้อนใชครับเวลาเครื่องรถเดินทำ
งานมันจะมีความร้อนน้ำจะช่วยให้ไม่ร้อน
อ่าจะช่วยให้เครื่องเนี่ยร้อนเอ่อน้อยลง
เพราะว่ามีความร้อนจากเครื่องเครื่องยนต์
น่ะจะเข้ามาที่น้ำนี้ค่ะอ่าน้ำก็ก็จะร้อน
เครื่องก็จะเย็นอออ่ะแต่ถ้าน้ำไม่มี
เครื่องก็จะร้อนเพราะว่าเครื่องไม่มีน้ำ
ที่ไปช่วยช่วยในการระบายความร้อนออกก็คือ
1 เดือนเติม 1 ครั้งใช่ครับน้ำมันก็จะ
ค่อยๆลดลงเหรอคะลดใช่ครับน้ำจะค่อยๆลดลง
นิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยไม่เยอะอ๋อไม่เยอะอเิม
นิดเดียวใช่ออนั่นแสดงว่าแสดงว่า 6 เดือน
เพื่อเอทำอะไรไม่เคยเติมเลย
ครับไม่เคยรู้ไม่เติมไม่แน่ใจว่าแฟนเอาจ
จะเติมให้ตอนหลังอาจจะไม่ได้เติมหรือ
เปล่าไม่แน่
ใจคือครูเอ๋ก็ไม่รู้นักเรียนรู้แต่ว่า
เฮ้ยรดเสียแล้วที่เขาบอกว่าหม้อน้ำรั่ว
เนี่ยก็คือตัวนี้หรือว่าตัวอื่นคะอ่าก็
ที่แทงค์น้ำที่เราเติมเนี่ยมันจะมีท่อไป
เข้าไปในเครื่องค่ะก็ระยะทางจากท่อจาก
แทงค์ไปที่เครื่องอาจจะมีท่อรั่วอ๋อใช่พอ
ท่อรั่วน้ำก็จะไหลออกออกๆออกไปอือ่าน้ำก็
จะหมดอ๋อก็ทำให้รถมีปัญหาใช่ๆก็ทำให้รถ
ร้อนแล้วก็มีควันขึ้นค่ะมีควันแบบนี้ออัน
นี้เคสที่ 1 นะอืหม้อน้ำแห้งใช่่มั้ยอ่า
หม้อน้ำแห้งเอครูเอกเคยเจอเคสหม้อน้ำแห้ง
ครั้งที่ 2 ครับอไปกับเพื่อนเหมือน
กันไปกับเพื่อนแต่ตอนนี้ไป 2 คนแต่เพื่อน
อีกคนหนึเพื่อนก็ขับรถใช่มั้ยคะเอ่าขับรถ
เอ๋น่ะขับรถไม่เป็นอืพอขับรถไปปั๊บเข้า
ปั๊มน้ำมันไม่ใช่ที่บ้านละครับแล้วเพื่อน
ก็บอกรถรถมีปัญหาอ่าปัญหาอะไรอีกครับที
นี้อ่ามันมันมันยังมีควันมีควันนิดๆนิด
เดียวอ่าครับมาจากไหนครับทีนี้กระโปรง
หน้า
อ๋อกระโปงหน้าอีกแล้วใช่เพื่อนคนนี้นะอ่ะ
เรียนมาเรียนมาอ่าครับเพื่อนก็บอกว่าเอ้ย
เอ๋หม้อน้ำแห้งชั่วเอออ่าเพื่อนก็บอกเอ๋
รอก่อนนะเดี๋ยเพื่อนก็ลงจากรถแล้วก็
วิ่งไปซื้อน้ำที่ที่ร้านสะดวกซื้ออ๋อมา
เติมใช่มั้ยโอเคใช่ซื้อเสร็จแล้วก็เปิด
เปิดแบบนี้เลยค่ะกุอาตี้อ่าเปิดฝากระโปรง
เหมือนเดิมใช่มั้ยอ่าเปิดฝากระโปรงนะคะ
คือควันไม่ได้เยอะขนาดนี้นะคะอ๋อมีควัน
นิดหน่อยใช่มั้ยอืแล้วเพื่อนก็ใช้ผ้าจับ
แล้วก็เห็นเคใช้ผ้าใช่ครับเพราะว่ามัน
ร้อนไงต้องใช้ผ้ารองก่อนมือจะได้ไม่ร้อน
ใช่เหมือนผ้าแบบเนี้ยอันนี้เสื้อผ้าใช่ๆ
แล้วก็เปิดแล้วเค้าก็เทน้ำโอ้โหครูอาตี้
ก็จะมีเสียงชใช่มันไม่มันไม่เสี่ดิมัน
อย่างงี้เลยค่ะเอาสีอะไรดีสฟู่ๆเลยเหรอ
ฟู่ขึ้นมามันพุ่งขึ้นไปเลย
ออพุ่งแบบอือน้ำเนี่ยขอโทษนะคะครูเอ๋กเอา
รูปนี้ให้เล็กๆอ่าเพราะว่าข้างในร้อนมาก
ไงครับเวลาเราเติมน้ำเข้าไปน้ำที่เราเติม
เข้าไปมันก็เดือดเดือดคู่ขึ้นมาน้ำพุ่ง
ขึ้นไปแบบเนี้ยค่ะอ๋อ
โอ้โหดีนะเอ๋
ก็ดีที่ 2 คนเนี่ยกระโดดต้องเรียกว่าอยู่
ตรงนี้ใช่มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ครับอยู่ตรงนี้น่ะ 2
คนน่ะกระโดดออกค่ะอืกระโดดออกไปไกลเลยอ่า
เนี่ยครับที่บอกว่าต้องรอก่อนรอให้เย็น
ก่อนสักนิดนึงนะครับอ่าจะได้ไม่มีน้ำพุ่ง
ออกมารอให้เย็นก่อนแล้วค่อยเปิดมันจะใช้
เวลานานมั้ยคะกว่าจะเย็นอ่าก็ใช้ประมาณ 1
ชั่วโมงครึ่งชั่วโมงขึ้นอยู่กับว่าร้อน
มากแค่ไหนโอโหถ้าประมาณนี้น่าจะรอ 1
ชั่วโมงเนาะใช่แต่ก็ไม่อันตรายไงไม่
อันตรายถ้ารอถ้ารอไม่อันตรายโอเคค่ะแต่
ถ้าไม่รอเนี่ยค่ะโรง
พยาบาลใช่อันนี้เรื่องจริงนะคะโรง
พยาบาลโอเคค่ะอันนี้เป็นเรื่องของหน้ารถ
นะคะแต่ทีนี้ที่หน้ารถอ่ะครูเออ๋มีอีกเคส
นึงของคนขับเพึ่งพึ่งหัดขับรถนะคะครับอ่า
เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋เอาตรงไหนดีอ่ะตรงนี้แล้วกัน
อ่อเคยขับรถไปต่างจังหวัดนะคะกับเพื่อน
ผู้หญิงอีกเหมือนกันแต่เป็นคนต่างชาตินะ
คะอ่านะไปขับขับรถไปด้วยกันแล้ววันนั้น
น่ะอยู่ในรถปึ๊บครูเอกอาจจะวัดรูปรถไม่
สวยนะคะนักเรียนครับอ่าไม่เป็นไรดูรู้ว่า
เป็นรถอ่าโอเคแล้วก็เพื่อนขับรถแต่ตรงนี้
เป็นกระจกหน้าอืนะคะกระจกหน้ารถแล้วก็ฝน
ตกอ๋ออืฝนตกไประยองจันทบุรีกันน่ะค่ะออไป
เที่ยวกันอีกแล้ว
ใช่คือข้างหน้าก็จะเป็นรถผู้ชายแต่ว่า
ข้างหลังเนี่ยคันเนี้ยผู้หญิงหมด
เลยผู้หญิงทั้งคันเลยอ๋อผู้หญิงทุกคนเลย
ที่ไปด้วยกันครั้งนี้ใช่ผู้หญิง 4 คนนะคะ
จริงๆ 4 คนไม่ใช่ 2 คนแต่ข้างหน้าเี่ก็จะ
มีผู้ชายมีอะไรไปแต่อันนี้ผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
อยากคุยกันไม่เอาผู้ชายบอกไม่เอาผู้ชาย
อยู่รถเรา
ออปรากฏว่าฝนตกครับแล้วถนนเนี่ยค่ะครู
อาตี้เป็นดินแดงดินน่ะอ๋อเป็นดินสีแดงใช่
มครับใช่แล้วมันก็
กระเด็นไม่รู้อมันมาอยู่ข้างหน้ารถอ่ะอ่า
เวลาที่เป็นถนนดินเราก็ต้องขับช้าๆใช่มย
ใช่ขับไปขับไปเสร็จอ่าแล้วเพื่อนก็ก็กด
ที่อ่าที่ปัดน้ำฝนใช่มั้ยใช่ปัดน้ำฝนออก
ไปจะได้มองเห็นตัดน้ำฝนอือฮึอ่าทีนี้ฝนตก
อันเนี้ยเป็นฝนตกแบบภาษาไทยเรียกว่าฝนตก
ปลอยๆละอ๋อฝนตกไม่หนักฝนตกนิดหน่อยใช่
มั้ยตกปลอยๆอืถ้าฝนตกหนักๆแล้วเราปัด
เนี่ยโอเคเลยใช่มั้ยคะใช่ๆครับอ่าแต่ฝนตก
ปลอยๆเนี่ยแล้วดินดินที่เป็นสีแดงๆ
กระเด็นใช่ครับเเรียกกระเด็นเนาะอ่า
กระเด็นขึ้นมาอยู่บนบนหน้ากระจกรถใช่มย
ใช่อ่าถ้าอย่างนี้เนี่ยแล้วพอปัดปั๊บโห
กระจกรถสีแดงใช่เราก็จะมองไม่เห็นมองไม่
เห็นไปไม่ได้ขับไป 5 เมตก็ต้องเอาทิชชู่
ไปเช็ดแล้วก็ไปอีกแล้วก็จอดแล้วก็เช็ดอื
อือฮึจนเพื่อนทุกคันก็บอกเฮ้ยทำไมมันมา
ช้าจังทุกคนก็รถจะชนมยรถเสียทำไมอ่ะทำไม
ทำไมทำไมไม่มีน้ำน้ำอยู่ที่ไหนออือฮึตรง
เนี้ต้องมันเป็นน้ำหม้อไหนคะครูอาติอ่า
โอเคต้องเป็นน้ำที่อยู่ใน
เอ่อเป็นน้ำที่อยู่ในถังของที่ที่ฉีดน้ำ
หน้ารถครับที่หรืออาจจะเรียกว่าที่ปัดน้ำ
ฝนอันนี้ป่ะเกี่ยวมยอ่าอันนั้นไม่ใช่ครับ
อันนั้นเป็นน้ำมันมีอยู่ด้านข้างครับมี
อยู่ด้านข้างเป็นหม้อเอ่อเป็นกระป๋องสี
ขาวๆใหญ่ๆใหญ่กว่าของหม้อน้ำเมื่อกี้ครับ
อ๋อในรูปนี้น่าจะไม่มีเนาะอ่าใช่ครับอยู่
ด้านข้างอเห็นมีรูปนี้มาเนาะอ่ะตรงนี้อ่า
ใช่ๆนี่ด้านซ้ายมือตรงนี้อ่าอันนี้นะคะอ
เป็นถังเก็บน้ำฉีดกระจกนี่นะคะอ่าฮะเรียก
ว่าถังเก็บน้ำฉีดกระจกเนาะใช่ครับออืก็ก็
จะมีน้ำอ่ะมีน้ำออกมาใช่ครับเวลาเราปัด
ใช้ที่ปัดน้ำฝนแล้วก็มีน้ำออกมาด้วยเก็จะ
ล้างล้างดินที่กระเด็นจากพื้นมาโดนหน้ารถ
ก็จะใช้น้ำเนี่ยล้างออกไปเวลาปัดกระจกก็
จะกลับมาสะอาดมองเห็นเหมือนเดิม
อืเชื่อมว่าทุกคนที่รดสีคนไม่
[เพลง]
รู้อ่าถ้ายงงั้นเราเราต้องไม่ปัดไม่ปัด
ขับไปแบบที่มีจุดจุดของดินใช่ตอนแรกปัด
แล้วมีปัญหาก็ต้องขับจอดแล้วก็เช็ดขับจอด
แล้วก็เช็ดรถข้างหน้าทุกคนก็เอ๊ะหายไปไหน
เพราะว่าเป็นถนนที่ไม่มีปั๊มน้ำมันไม่มี
อะไรเลยนะคะจนสุดท้ายเนี่ยตามทันเพื่อน
เออตามทันเพื่อนก็เลยบอกทำไมทำไม
ช้าไปไม่ได้ข้างหน้าสีแดงหมดแล้วอ่าเช็ด
กระจกอยู่เช็ดกระจกขับไปเช็ดไปใช่เพื่อน
ก็ถามทำไมไม่ใช้ที่ปัดน้ำฝนเออเราก็บอก
ว่าปัดแล้วยิ่งแย่เพื่อนก็เลยเอ๊ะทำไม
เพื่อนก็เลยเช็ครถให้อ๋ออืน้ำหมดอ่าน้ำ
ที่ปัดน้ำฝนหมดโอเคหมดก็มีปัญหานะคะก็
ต้องใส่ขอบคุณอตี้ค่ะตอนนี้เข้าใจเพิ่ม
ขึ้นละครับขอบคุณเพื่อนมาอ่ะครูอาตี้มี
อีกคำถามค่ะอ่ามีปัญหากับรถอีกใช่มั้ครับ
อ่ามีปัญหาอะไรครับทีนี้ตัวเนี้ค่ะคือครู
เอกสงสัยว่าอันเนี้ยน้ำกลั่นอ่าใช่ครับ
อันนี้น้ำกลั่นใส่ที่ไหนค่ะอ่าใส่ใน
แบตเตอรี่ครับตรงนี้ใช่มยคะใช่ที่ในรถ
ยนต์จะมีแบตแบตรี่อยู่นะครับถ้าเรามารูป
นี้อยู่ตรงไหนอ่ะอ่าอยู่ขวามือครับสี
น้ำเงินสีน้ำเงินอออันอันนี้เหรอค่ะใช่
อันนี้คือแบตเตอรี่ใช่ครับอ๋ออจะมีที่
เติมน้ำกลั่นอยู่โอเคถ้าเรามาดูใกล้ๆก็
คือแบบนี้ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ๆครับอ่าอันนี้เป็น
สีดำนะครับเติมครั้งละเท่าไหร่คะ 1 ขวด
อ่าข้างในด้านข้างเห็นมั้ยครับด้านข้างจะ
มีขีดอยู่ 2 เส้นเห็นมั้ยครับ
หืด้านด้านข้างของแบตเตอรี่เห็นมั้ยครับ
ตรงไหนอ่ะอ๋อๆๆเห็นแล้วเหใช่ๆมีขีด 2
เส้นเหมือนเดิม
อ๋อครูเอ๋ก็หาใหญ่เลยอนักเรียนคะขีดให้
เห็นๆนะคะขีดบนกับขีดล่างอ่าขีดล่างเพราะ
ถ้าน้ำอยู่ที่ขีดล่างต้องเติมต้องเติม
แล้วอ๋อเติมขึ้นมาให้อยู่ขีดบนคือมองเห็น
เลยใช่มั้ยคะใช่ใช่ครับอ๋ออออ๋อแล้วเติม
ครั้งนึงอย่างรถคูตี้อ่ะต้องกี่ขวดคะอ่า
รถคูตี้เติมครั้งนึงประมาณประมาณครึ่งขวด
อ๋อหรอไม่ไม่ไม่ต้องเยอะใช่มั้ยคะไม่เยอะ
ใช่ครับไม่เยอะ 1 ขวดเท่าไหร่นะอันเนี้ย
อ่าราคาเหรอครับใช่ขวด 1 ลิตรครับ 1 ลิตร
อ่ากี่บาทอ่ะ1ลออราคาประมาณ 20 บาทครับ
อ๋อใช่ไม่แพงไม่แพงที่ไหนคะอ่าตามร้าน
เอ่อร้านที่ไปขายอะไหล่เครื่องยนต์ก็มีอื
ใช่ครับร้านวัสดุก่อสร้างก็มีครับอื
สมมุติว่าถ้าน้ำในแบตเตอรี่หมดจะเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นค่ะอ่าถ้าน้ำในแบตเตอรี่หมดก็ไม่มีไฟ
ไม่มีไฟฟ้าเวลาเรารถจอดอยู่ครูเอ๋กำลังจะ
ออกจากบ้านครูเอ๋ต้องเสียบกุญแจแล้วบิด
สวิตช์ค่ะใช้ไฟไฟฟ้าถ้าบิดสวิตช์แล้วไม่
มีเสียงแสดงว่าไฟหมดก็คือน้ำหมดคือน้ำใน
แบตเตอรี่ไม่มีแล้วอ๋อใช่ครับถ้าอย่าง
งั้นสมมติว่าตอ๋อแต่ใกล้ๆบ้านไม่มีเราก็
โทรศัพท์แต่ตอนนี้เรียก LINE  Man ได้
เนาสั่งแบตเตอรี่ลูกใหม่ะถ้าน้ำหมดคือ
ต้องสั่งแบตเตอรี่ลูกใหม่เลยเหรอคะใช่ใช่
ครับ
อ๋อ
ไม่ไม่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่สั่งน้ำกลั่นมาเติมไม่
มีอ๋อไม่ได้สั่งน้ำกลั่นเติมก็เติมน้ำไม่
ได้เติมไฟฟ้า
ครับอ๋อถ้าอย่างงั้นแปลว่าอน้ำแบตเตอรี่
หมดไม่ได้ใช่ครับหมดไม่ได้ถ้าเกิดว่าน้ำ
ระบายในในในอะไรนะอ่าในหม้อน้ำอ่าในที่
ปัดน้ำฝนถ้าหมดก็เติมได้โอเคเแล้วก็ขับไป
ได้เหมือนเดิมค่ะแต่ถ้าน้ำของแบตเตอรี่
หมดแปลว่าต้องเปลี่ยนแบตเตอรี่เลยอ่าต้อง
เปลี่ยนแบตเพราะว่าแบตจะเสียอ๋อใช่ครับ
แล้วเวลาเราเจิมน้ำในหม้อแบตเนี่ยใช้ 1
ครั้งใช้ได้นานเท่าไหร่อ่าประมาณประมาณ 3
เดือนหรือ 6 เดือนก็ได้ข้อยู่กับว่าขับ
ขับเยอะยถ้าขับเยอะๆก็อาจจะ 3 เดือนดู
ครั้งนึงออก็แสดงว่าเราจะต้องเปิดดูแต่
ไม่ต้องเปิดดูทุกวันใช่มั้ยคะใช่ไม่ต้อง
เปิดดูทุกวันไม่ต้องมีโอกาสจะรั่วมั้ยคะ
อ่ามีโอกาสจะรั่วมั้ยไม่มีอหมายถึงว่า
หมายถึงว่าน้ำในแบตเตอรี่นี่แบตเตอรี่
รั่วและน้ำออกไม่มีใช่มั้ยคะอ๋อไม่มีครับ
ถ้ามีก็แสดงว่าชนรถชนแรงๆแล้วแบตเตอรี่
แตกอือ่าปกติน้ำในแบตเตอรี่ไม่รั่วค่ะใช่
ครับอือฮึอือืโอเคเข้าใจแล้วครูเอ๋ก็นึก
นึกว่าถ้าแห้งก็อ้าเอาน้ำกลั่นมาเติมให้
หน่อยไม่ได้ใช่มไม่ได้ไม่ได้ต้องยกมมอบ
เค้าเรียกอะไรนะยกแบตเตอรี่ยกแบตเตอรี่
อ่ายกออกแล้วก็เปลี่ยนใหม่ก็ได้หรือหรือ
ถ้าไม่อยากจะเปลี่ยนใหม่เอาไปซ่อมได้เอา
ไปชาร์จไฟเข้าไปชาร์จต้องไปที่อู่ซ่อมรถ
ให้เขาชาร์จเข้าไปออแล้วเราจะเอารถไปได้
ยังไงล่ะก็ก็อ้าก็ต้องให้ที่ชร้านช่างมา
เอาแบตเตอรี่มาอีกลูกนึงอเอรอนึๆนึกว่ามา
ยกไปมายกไปก็ได้ครับหรือจะเอาแบตเตอรี่มา
อีกลูกนึงแล้วก็เอามาวางแล้วก็สตาร์ทรถ
จากแบตเตอรี่ของช่างอ๋อรถเราก็สตาร์ทได้
แล้วก็ขับไปที่ร้านที่ร้านซ่อมให้เขา
ชาร์จแบตเตอรี่เข้ารถของเราอ๋อคือเขาจะ
ชาร์จเข้าแต่ว่าไม่ต้องยกแบตออกใช่ใช่
ครับอแล้วแล้วอย่างงี้แบตจะอยู่มีอายุได้
นานอีกเท่าไหร่ก็ใช้ได้อีกนิดหน่อยแต่ไม่
นานเหมือนเดิมแล้วไม่เหมือนเดิมแล้วใช่
ครับก็คือเปลี่ยนดีกว่าใช่มเปลี่ยนดีกว่า
ครับอืออย่าเสี่ยงใช่มั้เกิดไปเสียที่ภู
เขาขึ้นมายุ่งนะคะใช่ๆอนะคะอ่ะโอเคเรายัง
มีเวลามั้ยคะอ่าเหล่าหมดเวลาพอดีครับวัน
นี้อ๋อโอโอหเอ๋กยังมีคำถามอย่างอึ่นอีก
ไม่เป็นไรอ่าวันนี้นักเรียนรู้เรื่องอะไร
บ้างครับวันนี้มีวันนี้รู้เรื่อง
เอ่อรู้เรื่องเนี่ยค่ะหม้อน้ำแห้งใช่มย
หม้อน้ำแห้งอ่าแล้วก็น้ำที่ปัดน้ำฝนใช่
ไม่มีเหมือนกันอ่าที่ปัดน้ำฝนก็น้ำแห้ง
เหมือนกันที่ปัดน้ำฝนตรงนี้นะคะฝนตกก็น้ำ
อ่าที่ปัดน้ำฝนก็แห้งแล้วก็อ่าไม่มีน้ำ
น้ำในแบตเตอรี่น้ำแบตเตอรี่แห้งเหมือนกัน
แห้งนะคะอันนี้ไม่ดีน้ำแห้งไม่
ดีรถจะไปไม่ได้นะคะใช่ครับต้องดูแลบ่อยๆ
ช่างจะยิ้มนะ
คะเสียเงินเสียเงินใช่โอเควันนี้ครูอาตี้
เขาก็เป็นช่างนะคะครูเอ๋ปรึกษาถ้าวันนึง
ครูเอ๋จะขับรถแล้วมีปัญหาจะได้เข้าใจนะคะ
อ่าใช่ว่าทำยังไงโอเคค่ะขอบคุณค่ะูออ่า
เดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่คราวหน้าครับ
วันนี้เรา 2 คนต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วครับอ่า
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย
บ